you were studying studying
iconography and that allowed you to see
the world and see stories through a
particular lens
yeah i was watching you give an
interview i mean i was watching you have
a conversation about the spider-verse
with someone yeah and that person then
made a comment about some other some
other aspect of the spider verse and
then you said oh and what that could
mean is this this this and this
and then the guy said oh i didn't see
that before and then you said oh i
didn't see it before until you mentioned
it
and that made me realize you that's not
something you
thought about because for a tr for a
regular person
a regular person who's even watching
this they would have to sit and think
okay what could the spider verse mean to
here's what i know okay
okay okay this fits in here this fits in
here this doesn't work okay okay and
then it would take them maybe 20 minutes
to come up with something
that you came up with in a in the span
of a sentence or two
which means you actually see the world
or you've thought about it for so long
that it's just second nature to you and
i want to know how did that develop and
how do you see the world so do you see
people
walking down the street differently than
you used to no i mean that seriously
because even people who study physiology
they can tell people's ailments
just by watching them walk even if they
look like they're normal oh you you
slightly tilt in this direction
it's almost like sherlock holmes and so
you see people moving
towards the subway and then you think
okay that's a that's a place of
communion where people don't interact
that's almost like what we had in the
12th century when this happened and this
happened
so i want to know do you see the world
like that no i see
i and how did you start to see the world
the way you see the world
um i mean i think i i see the world
through patterns that's for sure
okay now when you say patterns i'm going
to get specific here so when you say
patterns
you mean repetitions parts
of life that repeat or parts of life
that are abstracted so for example
there's a pattern of talking or i talk
you talk i talk utah now that's a
pattern okay so repeating
or another pattern is is you abstract
out from a certain set
so there's a pattern of what it means to
be human right so
it's i would say
okay so the pattern you could say the
pattern starts
with how things exist right
and when i say how things exist what i
mean is how they exist
phenomenologically not in terms of
science
because that's what confuses you in
terms of experience in terms of
experience
how we experience things existing and
that's really the basis of how things
exist
no matter what we say like we we we try
to push beyond
the phenomenological but we always see
it through the lens so the scientist
even though he has all the scientific
categories
he's still in a consciousness and
looking at the world through that
consciousness
and or she he or she he or she yeah just
just don't send any letters
um and so the the way that something for
exa
i'll give you a perfect example so the
way that something exists
you need for something to exist to have
it have an identity
right and then have a you could say
a variety say it that way you need to
have an identity and a variety or a
oneness and a multipleness to it can you
give me an example
well so if i have a so i i have
a cup so this has an identity and it's
it's let's say it's identity is
is the cup that's part of it has it has
other identities but let's use that one
for
for start so it has an identity it's a
cup but then it also
it also is not just
there is no such thing as a cup it's
actually non-binary and it's offended
that you defined it in terms of
well there's no such thing as a there's
no pure cup
right not in the world right so a cup
has to have
and has to have a particular
particularity to it
right and the particularity to it is its
variety it's a multiplicity
and then in order for it to have
particularity then it has to
embody other identities so it has a
color it has
you know it has to have a color right
but it there's no color in the cup
cup doesn't have color but it has to
have color so there's there's the
concept of cupness
which doesn't actually exist in the
world in space and time
but it's a concept nonetheless something
that makes something interesting
essence it's a concept i try not to get
too tied up in
because people say okay you're being
playtonic just trying to to see
how things come to to exist and so so
there's an aspect of it which is one
there's an aspect of it which is
multiple and everything
always has to to to have that for
anything to exist
has to be one and multiple at the same
time because it also has to be
constitutive
constituted by parts okay so you're
saying the elements of this that are not
a cup are
but also for even for it to be a cup it
also needs to be
constituted with parts so it has one
oneness then it also has parts which are
multiple and the
the cuppness of the cup holds the cup
together right so let's just say that
just have one and one in many
okay okay so if you have one in many
just that
yeah you already have a basic pattern
and then you could look at the world
through one in many
and and you can notice when things move
towards one
or when they move towards many or how
they move towards one
how they move towards many